what is softbank a really difficult
question to answer these days
telecoms group it's a semiconductor
group it's now more of an investment
group
a huge and very aggressive hedge fund it
is the corporate expression
of one man a journey for
people to ride alongside the mind of
masayoshi's son
it's like a jigsaw puzzle right at the
centre of it you've got masayoshi-san
the 63-year-old founder of softbank he's
like no other
chief executive in japan he is not
afraid of taking risks
he's a risk-addicted billionaire he's
not afraid to make extremely aggressive
bets
if we were in a casino he'd be the guy
doubling down every time he wins with
his money if he's on the blackjack table
just double down
double down double doubt he never takes
the chips off the table and he just lets
it ride as far as he can go
he's exploring ways to become rich
exploring ways to change the world he
identified technology
as the way to do that in next 10 years i
would
continue to invest more and more
he's driven by power the desire to make
soft bank one of the world's biggest
companies
he's not really into inventing things so
it's not like softbank creates products
he's more
investing in vision if you go in the
room and ask for 100 million dollars and
he says well i was going to give you 500
million
so why do you only need a hundred if you
don't have a good answer for the 500
you're not getting the money
he gets frustrated with us journalists
he gets frustrated with investors
who don't value his company as highly as
he thinks it should be valued
he's small physically small and he's
calm what lies beneath
is this vigorous shark
masai shison is born and raised in japan
he left japan
to study in the u.s he came back to
japan
using the money from a patent that he
sold of an electronic translator
he set up softbank in 1981 as a software
distributor
his breakthrough deal came in 2000 when
he invested 20 million dollars in
alibaba just the year after the chinese
company was created
to turn 20 million into 100 billion and
more that doesn't happen you know even
the best venture capitalists
in the world who put a sliver of money
in airbnb
or a sliver of money and google they
never have hit anything like that he's a
kind of film script version of what
happens if we all went back in time
and invested in facebook on the day that
it was invented and so on when the
market turns on softbank
the thing that keeps the market
confident that it's still worth
something is that he's still clutching
on to that
alibaba stake even through the pandemic
we've seen alibaba only get stronger and
its
share prices go higher we all want to be
that investor he actually was that
investor
what if it was a fluke did he just get
lucky on chinese e-commerce
you come back to the puzzle is he the
world's most astute tech investor
or is he the luckiest guy on the planet
he listened to jack ma's speech for five
minutes and he saw the twinkle in his
eyes
and decided to invest in the company
him right we're the same animal
you believe in the future he probably
has the biggest
guts in the world on doing investment
yeah right very few people in the world
have that courage
too much god sometimes i lose a lot of
money i don't
he had so much conviction in jack ma and
what the potential of alibaba was that
all these times that it was in the money
he never took a penny off the table
he just wanted to ride it and he's been
proven right it's one thing to find
alibaba which is
already impressive but it's another to
have the conviction to stick with it
the problem is that last autumn jack ma
made a
pretty ill-advised speech in shanghai
and
it seemed to take a swipe at regulators
the next thing we know the share price
of alibaba's taking a really really big
hit
big problem there is that softbank is a
25 holder of alibaba stock and where
goes alibaba
goes softbank it's kind of hard to
describe softbank in one word
it has so many pieces its investment
portfolio is diverse it has obviously at
stake in the domestic mobile business
the now separately listed mobile
business that has been absolutely
core and a lot of investors have
invested in softbank because of the
stability that this telecoms business
offers the 2006 vodafone japan
deal that's a key moment because it
creates a ballast to keep the company
stable
[Music]
almost important as buying vodafone's
japan business
was the decision to be the launch
carrier for the apple iphone you have
you know this outsider offering an
american phone to japanese consumers and
the whole question of whether
japanese consumers would dump the
japanese product
in favor of american products like
everything he does it was a gamble
and it obviously paid off enormously the
underlining theme of course is
softbank's investment the future of
technology the current state of the
puzzle
it's in flux because one of the key
pieces is in the process of being sold
which is arm
you asked me four or five years ago what
softbank is i would say softbank is a
company
with arm at the core and masa running
around the world telling everyone that
this company
and its chip design will be the basis
upon which the internet of things will
be built off of all these connected
devices
he didn't have the money to pay for arm
and so he needed to find
people who would put money in to back
the transaction
what he does discover is that there's a
bunch of capital in the middle east
that just wants to invest with it and
that's how we get the vision fund the
vision fund launched in 2017
as the world's largest technology fund
the largest investors in the fund were
the sovereign wealth fund of a abu dhabi
saudi arabia was also a big investor
it was really a marriage of mines
between mohammed bin salman and
masayoshi on the one hand a young
authoritarian leader who's in a hurry to
transform a society and wean it off oil
tech obsessed but is very concerned
about looking like dumb money on the
global stage so in comes masa and says
look
i'm the world's best technology investor
and i have arm and i can see the future
of connected devices and you're trying
to build these mega cities in saudi
arabia
let's do this together fast forward to
today
arms operations under softbank basically
stung the high-tech stuff the stuff that
was the future
is basically a cash-guzzling
cash-burning disaster
if he's nothing else he is a consummate
salesman
he got asked once so how did you
convince mohammed bin salman to give you
45 billion dollars in an hour and he
says no
45 billion dollars in 45 minutes 1
billion every minute
you've got so much money in a fund
you're not just
buying a little part of that industry
you're buying the future of that
industry
100 billion dollars with which he can
say okay okay maybe the market was one
day going to come to the conclusion that
this company was going to be the
dominant player but i'm going to
leapfrog all of that and just make this
company the dominant player by pouring
so much money into it what if he says
okay if you don't take my money i'm
going to go give quadruple that amount
to your rival
it's not all lovey-dovey people don't
see that brutal side of masa
he used capital as a weapon with the
vision fund
they poured money into various startups
from uber
dd oyo slack sent shockwaves through
silicon valley
and brought the valuations of technology
companies to new heights they wanted to
basically
be more effective at investing than
sequoia or benchmark
the brand name venture capital funds but
it's really a bunch of ex deutsche bank
traders who are running the show and so
what do they know about venture
investing
so the first few years of the vision
fund are marked by like
enormous mistakes these companies
weren't making money and when it came
time for them to do ipos investors
weren't convinced
we had this crisis that we work that
really raised questions in the vision
fund strategy
a office work sharing company sold into
this incredible hype machine
and the person feeding that hype of adam
newman founder was masa's son
i don't think he's necessarily the
greatest judge of character
he falls very hard in love with other
entrepreneurs i think if any of us stand
in a room with adam newman probably like
i'd probably tone down the crazy because
this is starting to look nuts
masa says no be more crazy and after the
pandemic struck
it also showed the vulnerability of
division fund with some of the
major bets like uber and dd being hit
and that led to softbank suffering its
biggest ever
annual loss but if you think about a
venture portfolio they're in 88
companies maybe slightly more their
point is some of them will be duds some
of them will be okay
and some of them may be alibaba level
potential maybe not the full alibaba
and as long as they get enough of those
it doesn't really matter what the other
stuff does
now you've got people so deeply involved
in some area of development particularly
the vision fund again
that they've become their own peace but
are never
more powerful than him at the center
recruited this
google man called nikesh aurora indian
very successful
nikesh wanted masa to pay down his debt
take less risks
these two had a spectacular falling out
at the same time
another indian whose masa had recruited
rajiv mizrah from deutsche bank
his rise really begins and takes off as
nikesh's plummets
he brings in a guy called sago he is
goldman sachs in japan super cautious
and so you've got deutsche and goldman
sachs characters now
merged you've got a lot of complexity
around everyone second guessing what
everyone else is up to
another character was marcelo clau who
was recruited into softbank and then put
in charge of sprint
and is now playing a major role across
the portfolio the wild west is how the
vision fund's been
described internally he likes a little
bit of chaos and he likes a little bit
of tension
it's a pirate ship and it's full of
pirates and they're all aggressive
traitors
and what you have is basically masa as
the ring leader of this pirate ship
they're not coordinated they don't get
along everyone is briefing against each
other
that tension is all held in place when
he's there
but then i think we do come back to this
question of how long
masayoshi's son is going to be in charge
of this
and whether softbank survives
him not being at the center of that
puzzle
right before the arm deal nikesh leaves
and this is the person that was the
anointed successor masa is now 63 years
old it doesn't seem like he has a
successor
because so much of this company is
associated with his vision
that also creates a big risk for
softbank the whole structure would
collapse if something happened to masa
someone could make a play
for the run for the top it's not the end
of the world but it's pretty close
if you have a company that is run with
such obvious deference to
one person's views you've got governance
issues you've got questions about
whether the board is a real board
whether it can stop him doing something
that's manifestly insane
2020 has been crazy year for softbank
masa became
very exposed whose entire wealth is
effectively in softbank shares
when the stock of soft bank starts going
down the banks who with whom he's
borrowed
get very nervous so masa in the middle
of march
went into some crisis meetings with his
key executives
and eliot the hedge fund which has an
activist stake in in softbank and has
been calling for it to do share buybacks
the assumption was that elliot would end
up in a nasty clash with son but
ultimately
they wouldn't get anywhere lo and behold
the buybacks begin
maybe the investors are getting
somewhere maybe governance is changing
with this company
it triggered this massive asset disposal
which was initially designed to carry
out share buybacks
and also to reduce debt to and to
restore investor confidence the arm
gets agreed to be sold to nvidia in a 40
billion dollar deal
you have the japanese telecoms unit they
announce a plan to bring down their
control to raise money
they have sprint which they've merged
with t-mobile another part of the jigsaw
puzzle
he's very politically savvy he can
strike up a relationship with most of
the world's leaders whether it's donald
trump or vladimir putin
and from the moment trump was elected
president masa was courting him
he needed the sprint deal to get through
massa goes to trump tower
and says to him i'm going to create 50
000 new jobs in america i'm going to
invest 50 billion dollars
u.s regulators finally allowed sprint
and t-mobile to merge he'd crack the
code of trump
now it's flush with money so it has 80
billion in cash
one thing you should never expect masa
to do is to have cash in the bank
account and not spend it
and that's how you get to the other
piece of the jigsaw puzzle that nasdaq
whale story
towards the end of august 2020 we
started to notice some quite strange
stuff going on in u.s stock markets and
particularly
in tech stocks the nasdaq index the
composite and the nasdaq 100 were both
up about
12 13 over the month tesla was up
70 odd percent and amazon and google and
all these
stocks had an absolutely blistering run
the options market is a place where
investors can effectively
bet on future stock price movements or
try and hedge themselves against them
the talk was of a whale a huge account
people couldn't figure out who it was
that was just
gobbling up these options our sort of
ringing around
on this led us to softbank our instincts
were saying
someone's got this wrong but to our
surprise it turned out to be
right massey son says it's actually in
line with this vision
because it's investing in the future of
ai and he believes that you know the big
us giants like facebook amazon and
google they're all
kind of the front runners in the ai race
but obviously investors
don't always agree with that idea so the
next day
shares in softbank itself fell pretty
heavily took about nine billion dollars
off the market cap of softbank that day
the strategy was being directed
specifically by
massason this came from the top and that
tells you a lot about
massason as a character he's not afraid
to take the market completely by
surprise he's not afraid to make
extremely aggressive
bets in markets that he doesn't normally
play in i mean
veterans in the equities options market
were telling us they'd never seen
anything like the scale of
the bets that were going on here it
started to look at a certain point like
softbank was morphing
into a huge and very aggressive hedge
fund this is not something that's sat
easily with the market
he doesn't really respect the stock
market he doesn't really respect stock
market investors
but he needs it because he's so
aggressive that he needs the sources of
capital
to be risk addicted and to buy at the
rate he buys
really means that he borrows more than
almost anyone we know and what you have
is a company that constantly changes
because
he's constantly experimenting it's
impossible to second guess
you never know where softbank are going
to crop up next you never know what
market they might start dabbling in
in huge size and with very aggressive
strategies a few weeks down the road or
even a few days down the road softbank
could have another
massive transformative deal and we'll be
talking about a new definition for
softbanks kind of depends on you know
where that vision that massage song has
next
he's a gambler and he takes big risks
and he's
undoubtedly successful i really don't
see a scenario where masa hoards cash
ultimately we come back to the casino
and the question is are you going to
take your chips off the table and walk
away or are you going to push it all out
and go all in
everything in his career suggests that
he's always all in